>>Daniel Goleman: Every parent of
course is the first coach for kids
in focusing and self control.
Parents do it naturally.
The moment you pick up
a toddler who's crying
and you soothe her,
you help her calm down.
You're actually modeling
for her that behavior
and her brain is learning
how to calm down on its own.
Kids are constantly learning lessons
from their parents from infancy
on about managing emotions.
One of the reason is when a child is
first born it actually does not have
in its brain the circuitry
for modulating a distress.
That's why a baby will
express whatever it feels.
So a parent is continually
modeling for a child how you manage
that impulse to run in front
of the car, to hit the kid,
to do all the things that
you're telling a two year old
or a three year old or four
year old, "No, don't do that."
"Just say no" circuitry becomes
internalized for kids and they learn
to manage their own emotions.
And schools that have
social emotional learning,
that have teachers who care, that
have lessons in paying attention
and in managing your
emotions are simply continuing
and complementing what
good parents do anyway.